[Music]
marvel studios loki is finally here on
disney plus and i got to talk to the
director kate herron take a look
so hi kate great to talk to you today
hey no thanks for having me how did you
get to be involved with loki and what
drew you into that character i guess
what drew me into the character was i
suppose like everyone right like i saw
thor and i i completely was like
fascinated with you know the character
and tom's performance and i'm always
kind of drawn i think to kind of
outsiders and i i also love villains
like i think that you don't necessarily
have to agree with what they're doing
but you have to understand why they're
doing it and i think tom brought such
empathy from thor he's gone on this
incredible journey and become you know
like almost like an anti-hero really
like across those like those films and i
found obviously they were making a tv
show and i love marvel like i used to i
think my first thing i fell in love with
marvel was the x-men cartoon and i just
have always
you know been like oh i'd love to work
on a marvel project and loki's like my
favorite i just basically asked my agent
i was like look i know i've only done
like a teen
comedy drama but just just see just see
call them up and just see and i i'd love
to speak with them so they've met with
me and they sent me like michael's first
script which was fantastic and i just
kind of went big with it i was just like
i'm gonna give them like a full download
of everything i'm excited by in the
writing and also just where i'm excited
where we could take the story and they
liked
what i brought to them so here i am
oh that's so great and as a 90s cartoon
fan i appreciate the x-men drop that
would appreciate that
but i was actually going to ask you
about that about how you bring your
voice into this series into the marvel
cinematic universe because it has a
timeline of its own so how did you have
that balance between what's been said
and how to bring your voice into it i
think for me like even just
stylistically
it was quite different what i was
pitching them because you know there's a
mystery running through our show and i
was really inspired by like filmoire and
detective stories and i was like oh it'd
be so cool to kind of bring that look to
it and how do we make this feel like a
new part of marvel because they've done
so much already and
i think it was a real challenge in doing
that which was very exciting to me now
you have a background in filmmaking but
also in comedy and so i would love to
know what brought you to both of those
things what what made you fall in love
with filmmaking and with comedy i i
think for me comedy in a weird way i was
quite i i'm quite shy and i think it and
my writing partners are comedian and i
think i just kept i was like you know
i'm just i wanted to make comedies and i
needed to meet comedians so i just
started doing like improv comedy
honestly as a way to meet comedians and
it really put me out of my comfort zone
and then filmmaking
i actually came to quite late to be
honest i love movies and i love going to
the cinema with my friends and i think
in my head i was like oh i'll be an
actor but i never really knew what
directing was to be honest or like as a
job and i had amazing teachers when i
was um around 17 18
and they just kind of opened my mind up
to what cinema can be and they
introduced me to you know like just the
greats i think i didn't realize you
could have a voice and make a film which
i know sounds silly but i just hadn't
really thought about it in that way and
i love storytelling and i felt like it
was kind of a job where i could take all
these things i love
and put them in one place were there uh
any challenges that you faced with
putting this series together whether it
was just the pressure of making it or
just the actual process of putting it
all together i suppose there's a
challenge in a sense that
you know
we filmed this like a six hour movie we
weren't filming episode by episode
marvel wanted to run it like a film in
the sense that normally with television
obviously you do like the show runner
system and it's very different and this
was like a very big undertaking so i
think for me the challenge was you know
like doing a good job and wanting to
take care of loki the character because
he's very beloved what did you expect
would you have any advice for any
aspiring filmmakers i had this thing
where when i graduated
i didn't film anything straight away and
i think part of it was confidence
because i was like oh i have to be like
perfect at this job before i can
actually do it and i would say just like
throw yourselves into the fire and just
go make something don't wait for things
to be perfect or a giant budget just go
make something well this this series
everything i've seen so far has looked
amazing i appreciate all the work that
you've put into it directing it so thank
you so much and it was so great to talk
to you today this was so wonderful no it
was fun cheers
oh that was so cool to talk to kate
herron marvel studios loki is now
streaming on disney plus
[Music]
you